This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and soil
sciences, doctor of veterary medicine
for post-do and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
Hello, hello everybody and welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. It is
pharmacist Fridays where we are
challenging assumptions, connecting the
dots, and uncovering simple truths that
can make a powerful difference in your
health journey. So folks, if you were
invited by somebody specific, make sure
that you get back with them as they took
the time and cared enough about you.
Tell them thank you for doing so and
make sure that you subscribe to our
channel. You can even go to
dailywithdoc.com
and sign up for our email list as
dailywithdoc.com is the sponsor of this
program. My name is Becca Dukes. I'm a
certified naturopathic practitioner,
certified
holistic health coach and the director
of student services for the Institute of
Holistic Health and the host and
producer of the Daily with Doc and Becca
show. It is my honor and privilege to be
able to be a resource for an amazing
community. So that's the main reason I
want you to get back with the person
that shared this program with you. Now
today's conversation may surprise you.
What is the one most overlooked cause
behind feeling like your body is feeling
apart? Could it be that it's something
that you do 20,000 times a day and not
even think about it?
So, it's breathing.
So, if you've ever said, "I'm exhausted
all the time. My muscles ache. My brain
feels foggy. I can't recover. I feel
anxious,
inflamed, or like my health is
spiraling." It could possibly be your
breathing patterns. And pharmacist Ben
is going to help us explore this
fascinating connection between breath,
oxygen delivery,
stress chemistry, circulation, cellular
energy, inflammation, nervous system
balance, and why symptoms that seem
unrelevant may actually be connected.
So, there's a lot of things that go on
when it comes to our breath. And I am
super excited as pharmacist Ben has
mentioned many times about breathing
in many of the different uh groups of
symptoms that people have brought to the
show. So, pharmacist Ben Fuches, hello
and welcome to pharmacist Friday.
>> Thank you, Rebecca. So, I thought we
were going to have a guest on who's
going to talk about breathing. Is that
not right?
>> No. No.
>> I thought you said there was somebody
just No, I thought there was some Wasn't
there a customer or client or something?
>> Somebody had told me that somebody that
had breathing problems was going to be
on and you were going to be discussing
this with them.
>> Well, there's there's there's a
difference between breathing and
breathing problems.
>> Okay.
>> So, so breathing problems
typically involve respiratory disease.
Breathing in general is obviously
something you have to do, but but
conscious breathing, paying everybody
breathes, right? If you're alive, you're
breathing. But conscious breathing,
paying attention to your breathing is
the fastest way to connect into your
autonomic or your automatic nervous
system. You got a voluntary nervous
system and you got an autonomic nervous
system. Your voluntary nervous system is
like you move your arms and move your
legs and pick up a glass of water, etc.
The autonomic nervous system is the
automatic nervous system. They call it
autonomic but basically it's the
automatic nervous system. You don't have
to think about it. Your stomach, your
heart, your liver, your breathing, etc.
Those are all controlled autonomically.
And the autonomic or automatic nervous
system is divided into two parts which
we talk about all the time, right? Your
emergency nervous system and your um
calm and calm nervous system, your fight
or flight or your rest and digest
nervous system, right? Remember what
those are called?
>> The sympathetic and the parasympathetic.
>> Yes. And for everybody out there
listening, you can sound really, really
intelligent if you throw those words
out. Sympathetic and parasympathetic.
Sympathetic nervous system is the
nervous system that is associated with
emergencies, fight or flight. It's very
important nervous system. Um it it's
what gets you out of bed in the morning.
It's what gets you out of a jam away
from lions and tigers and bears from an
evolutionary perspective. Um but it's
also associated with all diseases. All
disease
is sympathetically driven. Disease
you're out of ease. I I say all but most
disease most chronic degenerative
diseases have an element of sympathetic
intervation. Sympathetic nervous system
by the way the sympathetic nervous
system interestingly is activated by
food.
Is that interesting? Your emergency
nervous system is activated by food. Why
would that be you folks?
Well, I mean, one of them might be
sugar.
>> No, no. Why would food make Why would
food be considered an emergency to the
body?
>> Oh, cuz if the body is starving, then
it's
goes into the survival mode.
>> Why would food?
>> No.
>> Why would food not starving? Why would
food eating activate the sympathetic
nervous system?
Well, when you eat, then your body comes
out of
>> it's a d from an ev no from an
evolutionary perspective, eating was the
most dangerous thing we did.
Eating activated all of the emer from an
evolutionary perspective. We didn't have
great food for most of our life, most of
our um evolutionary existence as human
beings. So, eating activates the
sympathetic nervous system, which is one
of the reasons why the less you eat, the
longer you live. It's called
I mean that you look sound look a little
confused by that but that's interesting
huh
>> that is very interesting
>> eating will activate the sympathetic
nerves now eventually your digestive
system runs parasympathetically so your
parasympathetic nervous system will kick
in too but you got the point being that
you got to be really careful about
eating less you eat the longer you live
eating for granted and that's just
that's just a rabbit hole that's just a
digression I thought that was kind of
that's a kind of interesting point that
we don't recognize that eating is to the
body. Eating represents a danger. Also,
when you were eating, you were also um
more susceptible to attack by lions and
tigers and bears from an evolutionary
perspective because why?
>> No, because you weren't paying attention
to
>> you weren't paying attention. Exactly.
You're not paying attention. You're
eating. So, for for a lot of reasons,
eating activates the sympathetic nervous
system. Just as an aside, I thought I'd
throw that out. But the point about
breathing is the fastest way to tap into
to hack into if you will the autonomic
nervous system is the breath for better
or worse.
>> So you can use um if you have if you're
not breathing if you're breathing
shallow for example you're not breathing
deeply you will uh tell the body that
it's in an emergency state. The body
will kind of perceive that you're
breathing shallowly or rapidly and that
will activate the sympathetic nervous
system.
Alternatively, if you um if you breathe
slowly and deeply and calmly, you'll
tell the body it's safe, the brain it's
safe, and that will activate the
parasympathetic nervous system. And you
can experience this instantly. It's the
fastest way to calm the body down. Slow,
deep, rhythmic breathing. Now, there's
different kinds of breathing. Um there's
a I think I saw somebody talk about but
breathing on one of the Daily with Docs.
Did was that a Daily with Doc episode?
They've talked about butico breathing.
Have you ever heard of butico breathing?
>> I have not heard of it. So, it may have
been mentioned into the chat, but I
don't always see.
>> It was somewhere else. Somebody was
talking about breathing, which is a very
interesting kind of breathing that
doesn't deliver more oxygen. It actually
reduces something called over breathing,
but that's a whole another thing. I
don't want to I don't want to get into
that. I don't want to digress into that
too much for now. Breathing supplies
oxygen for energy and it removes carbon
dioxide. So, not only is it giving you
oxygen for energy, but you're also
blowing off carbon dioxide, which is
acidic. So, that's one of the best way,
it is the best way, it's the most
important way to um control blood pH.
And that's one of the reasons why it has
a calming effect. Oxygen is alkalinizing
and um carbon dioxide is acidic. And so,
uh, when you breathe deeply, when you
oxygenate, you will, um, alkalinize the
blood. And when you blow off carbon
dioxide, you will blow off acid.
Let me think about that here.
Oxygenation, I I I got to think about
that here. Oxygenation will slow deep
rhythmic breathing will alkalinize the
blood and blowing off carbon dioxide
will move acid, which also has an
alkalin effect, blowing off acid. So
breathing is the best way to stabilize
your blood pH. That's the way your blood
pH is supposed to be stabilized, by the
way. You
>> better than drinking alkaline water,
which is H2O.
>> Exactly. You're not going to alkalize
your blood by drinking alkalized. That's
silly. But you may get some minerals
with alkalized water. That's how they
usually alkalinize. So in any case,
breathing controls the nervous system.
Breathing acts like a bridge between
your mind and your body. Breathing acts
like a bridge between your unconscious
and your conscious. Breathing acts like
a bridge between stress and relaxation.
Slow breathing will activate the
parasympathetic nervous system. Rapid
breathing will activate the sympathetic
nervous system. So if you want if you're
tired when you're driving, for example,
you know how you you ever drive at night
and you're falling asleep kind of thing
or you haven't slept a lot and you're
you know what I'm talking about. You're
kind of nodding off. Fast breathing they
call the breath of fire through the
nose.
>> You probably heard of that. Breath of
fire. Yes. That will wake that will wake
you up. Um,
a lot of people hyperventilate when
they're anxious.
And so when you uh hyperventilate when
you're anxious, that's going to lower
your CO2 levels, reduce your blood flow
to your brain. It can induce dizziness,
feelings of panic, racing thoughts. A
lot of that an a lot of the symptoms of
anxiety have to do with
hyperventilation.
uh
but breathing practitioners will slow
the breathing down. That's one of the
that's one of the uh ways but breathing
works to to help with anxiety. Also,
sleeping sleeping issues can h a lot of
times people wake up tired because they
didn't breathe when they were sleeping.
snoring, sleep apneoa,
um dry mouth, morning fatigue, all these
all of these are signs that of poor
breathing of poor sleep breathing or
poor sleep oxygenation I should say and
that's one of the reason why we wake up
tired especially if you're snoring or
especially if you have you're overweight
or you have some di you have blood sugar
issues or you have sleep apnea issues
all of those can lead to morning fatigue
one thing that you can do Um, this is
kind of an interesting little trick
because a lot of times people will
breathe through their mouth when they
can't breathe through their nose. So
they'll they'll alternatively if you
wake up in the morning your mouth is
really dry. Does that ever happen?
That's sometimes that happen to you when
you're sick or you have like a cold you
can't breathe. But a lot of times people
will have that kind of just normally
they'll wake up with their mouth dry.
That's because they're breathing through
their mouth rather than through their
nose. You always want to breathe through
the nose rather than through the mouth.
There's nerves in the top of your right
in right where your uh in your um sinus
cavities that are associated with nitric
oxide which has a vasoddilating effect,
anti-inflammatory effect. You won't get
that nitric oxide effect, that nitric
oxide stimulating effect if you breathe
through your mouth.
So, um a trick you could do is tape your
mouth shut when you sleep. I have a
friend, she's 96 years old and she
sleeps with her mouth taped shut and
she's amazing.
>> She has all great energy and she
actually will sleep with her mouth tape
shut because she noticed that she was
sleeping um she was breathing through
her breathing through her mouth which is
evidenced by um dry mouth when you wake
up in the morning. Also, if you wake up
in the morning, you could pretty much
assume if you wake up in the morning
tired, you could pretty much assume that
there's something going on with your
breathing, especially if you're snoring
or especially if you have sleep apnea.
Snoring is a big it, you know, people
make jokes about it, but it's a really
it's a sign that there's something wrong
with your breathing and it can lead to
cardiovascular issues, high blood
pressure issues, um, as well as
respiratory issues and fatigue issues
when you wake up in the morning. Um, a
CPAT machine, you know what a CPAT
machine is?
>> I do.
>> The CPAT machine can sometimes help
people who feel tired when they wake up
in the morning by driving oxygen into
their respiratory tract at night. So,
while it's kind of awkward to brea to
sleep with a CPAT machine, it can help
you if you have if you wake up tired in
the morning, uh it can help you um
oxygenate while you're sleeping. It
drives oxygen into your uh respiratory
system while you're sleeping. It forces
oxygen under pressure.
Um the nose breathing through the nose
in addition to having in addition to
being important for nitric oxide the
nose filters dust um microbes it
humidifies um the air warms the air and
then it also helps produce the nitric
oxide. Nitric oxide is really really
important stuff as you probably know.
It's a vasod diilator, improves oxygen
uptake. Um it supports the immune
system, supports circulation. Nasal
breathing is nitric oxide breathing.
Also um the brain is consuming large
amounts of oxygen. Brain's 2% of the
body but it consumes 20% of the oxygen.
So breathing will affect concentration,
memory, focus, mental clarity. For older
folks who are dealing with diabetes or
sleep apnea, they may notice that um by
practicing breathing, doing breathing
exercises, they can improve their
memory, they can improve their mental
clarity, etc. Um especially for
Alzheimer's patients, you know,
Alzheimer's is considered to be a type
of diabetes. It may help with folks who
are dealing with Alzheimer's or any kind
of dementia for that matter. And then of
course, breathing is important for the
heart as well, the circulatory system,
the heart. Go ahead. I'm sorry.
>> Well, I have a question with the nasal
breathing. What about those that have a
deviated septum?
>> Yeah, that can affect nasal breathing.
That can affect breathing as well.
Deviate the septum is the middle part of
the nose. If it's deviated, that can
block off a block uh inhalation, block
uh when you inhale, the septum can block
um oxygenation or rest or inhalation.
Septum is the middle part of the nose.
It's supposed to stay in the middle. So,
you have two nostrils. If it's deviated,
that can block off one of the nostrils.
Um the cardiovascular system depends on
obviously depends on oxygen, atrial
fibrillation, ventricular tachicardia,
arrhythmias, those can all be caused by
poor breathing. In fact, oxygenation is
one of the best ways that you can slow
down the heart if you're dealing with
atrial fibrillation. Also, um anggina
um they'll give they they'll give you
nit nitroglycerin if you have anga to
open everything up. Ana is a sign of um
or oxygenation to the heart. So uh
slow deep rhythmic breathing can improve
heart health um improve uh blood
pressure. In fact uh one of the things
that happens when we have hypertension
is we're not breathing correctly.
Pressure will increase as the body
attempts to get more oxygen to the
tissues. So slow deep rhythmic breathing
can be a great way to lower blood
pressure. In fact activating the
parasympathetic nervous system is a
great way to lower blood pressure.
That's why I always say if you if you
sit in a a warm bath, your blood
pressure will naturally drop. The warm
bath activating the parasympathetic
nervous system. And then of course if
you're exercising um efficient breathing
can improve endurance, uh slow down
fatigue, um improve recovery, improve
cramping, improve oxygen utilization,
and probably
next to the lungs, what do you think the
most important structure in the body is
for breathing?
The diaphragm.
>> Oh, the diaphragm.
>> The diaphragm. That muscle in the
middle.
>> Diaphragmatic breathing.
>> Diaphragmatic means the brea when you
breathe deeply, the diaphragm goes down
and air goes in and then when you
exhale, the diaphragm goes up and it
pushes air out. That up and down action
acts like a pump. So, you can actually
have almost like a a second heart. That
pumping action can support heart health,
heart health, diaphragmatic breathing.
Um, also diaphragmatic breathing is also
important for the lymphatic system. The
lymph doesn't have a pump. The diaphragm
in many ways is the pump for the lymph.
So diaphra diaphragmatic breathing can
be important for detoxification, for
lympadeema, for um for the immune
system, for uh delivering fatty
nutrients to uh fatty nutrients to the
cells, fatty vitamins, hormones to the
cells. Uh let's see what else. Breathing
also has an effect on inflammation.
Chronic stress breathing, short
breathing will activate the sympathetic
nervous system and elevate inflammatory
cytoines and lucatriines, inflammatory
chemicals. So slow deep rhythmic
breathing has anti-inflammatory effects.
Slow deep rhythmic breathing can also um
be helpful if you're dealing with
emotional uh turmoil like fear or anger
kinds of issues. You know, they always
tell you count to 10 or take a deep
breath. By the way, it never works to
tell somebody to take a deep breath or
relax when they're really ticked off at
you. But nonetheless, if you do it
yourself, um you can find that you're
you actually are are calming yourself
down. Uh when breathing slows down, your
thoughts slow down. See if you notice
that. If you have racing thoughts,
notice that you're breathing shallow.
And if you slow down your breathing,
your thoughts will slow down too.
Tension will stabilize. U we have a a
part of our brain called the default
mode network. The default mode network
is associated with your internal
dialogue. Slow deep breathing calms down
the default mode network. Um it makes us
more aware or slow deep rhythmic
breathing makes you more mindful, more
aware. Um and then the butico breathing
method which is a little bit c a little
bit counter to the slow deep slow deep
rhythmic breathing that we talk about is
according to uh the butico people you
don't want to breathe too much. They say
that there's a thing called over
breathing. And um by breathing slowly,
you um don't blow off as much carbon
dioxide. By not blowing off as much
carbon dioxide, you actually um have get
better oxygen delivery because carbon
dioxide is an oxygen magnet. So by uh
slow if you breathe too fast or too much
according to the butico people you'll
have depressed or suppressed carbon
dioxide and that will impair oxygen
delivery. So they like to keep the
carbon dioxide levels somewhat high
think uh under the uh with the thought
the or the idea that carbon dioxide acts
like an oxygen magnet and the but
breathing people are always talking
about nasal breathing as well. Nasal
breathing is definitely what you want to
do. According to but you want to your
breath should be quiet and just not
noticeable. The uh but people say that
the healthiest breath is the breath that
you don't notice. So there's different
thoughts on it. You kind of have to
experiment. I do use boutique breathing
occasionally but I like slow deep
rhythmic breathing and I do breathing
exercises personally every morning.
There's tons of YouTube videos uh for
breathing exercises and it's better if
you decide that you want to practice
breathing, it's better that you you do
it you watch a video or you kind of uh
are trained by somebody because if you
breathe incorrectly
um that could be worse than not not
doing any conscious breathing at all. So
you want to make sure that you're kind
of watching a video or having some
instruction when it comes to practicing
conscious attentive breathing. I
personally like slow, deep, rhythmic
breathing. The body loves rhythm, number
one. It's why they have that the little
watch when you're hypnotizing you,
right? Okay.
>> The body loves rhythm. Rhythm activates
the parasympathetic nervous system. Deep
activates the diaphragm and slow tells
the body that it's safe. Tells the brain
that it's safe. So, I like the slow,
deep, rhythmic breathing. But the butico
people say to breathe less and to
breathe barely uh uh be not even be able
to notice that you're breathing. Breathe
really really quietly and softly.
>> Uh let's see what else. Now the the uh
what you were talking about earlier
about or the whoever was going to come
on as a as a client who's having
breathing issues that's a little bit
different. Yes.
>> Okay. So with this
um the client had intercostal lung
disease in 2018. They were told that
their only option was a lung transplant
that that would be the only option to
help. She thinks that there's mold in
the home. Um she has a bad case of MBFA
where she also has congestive heart
failure and major lympadeema.
So, um, obviously things are not moving
as they're not they're not moving as
well as they should be moving. Correct.
>> Correct.
>> So, what do you do? Move. First of all,
move your body. That's one of the most
important things to do is move your
body. Secondly, move your lungs.
And that by moving your lungs, practice
slow, deep rhythmic breathing,
especially diaphragmatic breathing.
Remember the diaphragm is going to
activate the the lymph. When the lymph
or any fluid doesn't move through the
the vessels fast enough, it starts to
leak things start to leak out. So you
have a circle circulatory system and all
the fluids are in vessels and they're
circulating around. As long as they're
circulating around the fluids keep
moving. that if something blocks the
fluid from moving either stagnation or
dirty blood or dirty lymph and the fluid
doesn't move as effectively it has a
tendency to leak out especially on the
on the return return return trip. So
keeping the circulatory system the lymph
and the and the uh blood moving
effectively is the way you want to
protect against edema. Now if you have
she has did you say she had
cardiovascular disease or heart failure
or something?
>> Uh congestive heart failure.
>> Congestive heart failure. Right. So uh
that's one of the reasons why the blood
doesn't circulate as effectively. So
really you can't work on the heart
directly but you can work on oxygenating
the blood and you can work on cleaning
the blood and that's the mo heart
failure is basically the heart's not
getting oxygen and that has to do with
blockages that has to do with um poor
circulation that could have to do with
dirty blood and do with a lot of things
activated stress response. So calming
the body down through oxygenation,
moving the blood through diaphragmatic
breathing, and through exercise. Those
are all the ways that you want to
address those kinds of issues. But go
over the list one more time. C uh
congestive heart failure, lympadeema,
>> interstitial lung disease.
>> Interest lung disease. Right. What else?
>> Um lympadeema.
>> Okay. And and CHS congestive heart
failure.
>> Yep. And she she thinks that the mold in
her home was part of her lung issues.
>> No, I mean it might have had might have
been part of it, but that's you have
bigger fish to fry than that. Is she
older?
>> Um I don't know exact age on
>> you know the thing about blaming mole.
We like to blame things. Germs, viruses,
heredity, mold, parasites. You know,
this is the blame thing. You You don't
have any control over mold. There's
mold. There's viruses. There's bacteria.
You have control over yourself. And so,
you want to blame your sugar. You want
to blame your diet. You want to blame
your digestive health. I don't mean
blame. I I'm trying to, you know, make
anybody wrong here, but you have power
here. You don't have power over mold,
but you have power over your digestive
health. You have power over your
breathing. You have power over your
stress levels. You have power over your
exercise and your meditation, your rest.
You have these are places where we have
locus of control. This idea of mold and
parasites which you hear sometimes
people blaming that doesn't serve us. We
want to see where we can control our
symptoms. Locus of control and there's
so many places where you can control.
Yeah, if you're in a moldy house that
might have an impact, but is she eating
perfectly well? Is she exercising all
the time? Is she, you know, is she is
she sleeping well? Is she meditating? Is
she staying away from sugar? Is she
nutritionally supplementing? You know,
these are all places where you can work.
>> Well, she's not very old. She's only 66.
>> Okay. And that's not that's not show
disease has gotten better since she
moved out of the old home.
>> Okay. Well, that inner, you know, mole
may have an impact, but is she better?
Is she her heart failure is gone? She
doesn't have any more heart failure.
Heart failure.
>> Oh, no. She currently has a bad case of
um congestive heart failure and major
lympadeema.
>> Yeah. So chances are pretty good she had
a respiratory problem. Does she smoke?
>> I don't know.
>> Okay. Well, that would be a big thing.
So it chances are
>> smoker.
>> Non-smoker.
>> Non-smoker. Yeah. So interstitial lung
disease interstitial means between the
cells or in the tissue um is going to
impair oxygenation. Impaired oxygenation
is going to keep the the heart from
getting enough oxygen. That's going to
slow the heart down. When the heart
slows down, that means the fluid is
going to slow down. The circulatory
fluid fluids are going to slow down.
That's going to cause the fluids to leak
out. That's edema. So, the whole thing
is about oxygenation.
It's unusual for somebody to have
interstatial lung disease just from
mold. So, I'd want to know like what
else was going on. There's also a
chicken and egg phenomena in the sense
that did the heart disease precede the
lung disease or did the lung disease
precede the heart disease because if the
heart disease preceded the lung disease
that's going to keep the lungs from
getting oxygenated. The lung disease
preceded the heart disease that's going
to keep the heart from being oxygenated.
So it's hard to say. I'd have to ask I'd
have to ask a few more questions to see
which came first. But the bottom line is
is you want to keep things moving. This
is a woman, a person who's everything is
slowing down,
right? So breathing, exercising,
movement, all of these are those are the
kinds of strategies I would be employing
for this gal. And then of course,
nutritional supplementation. By the way,
fuccoidin is very effective for lung
disease.
Fucoidin helps improve the slimy nature
of the lungs. The lungs have to be
slimy. In fact, that's one of the ways
fucoidin works. It improves what's
called the glycoalix which is the slime
on top of cells and that slime is
important for digestive health for
respiratory health um and fuccoidin
support slime also for immune health.
>> So pharmacist Ben I I need a little bit
of your pharmacist
wisdom here.
>> Okay. Well, you have an individual on a
blood pressure medication and a
diuretic.
>> Yeah.
You do not want them just to cold
turkey. Is that correct?
>> Um the diuretic is isn't Yeah, I
wouldn't want to I would ne I would
never cold turkey any drugs. I would
never uh drugs that you're on for, you
know, chronic the kind of drugs that
you're on all the time. Aspirin or, you
know, headache kinds of drugs, that's
not a big deal. Pain pills, that's not
as much as important. But if you're on a
drug chronically, like
anti-hypertensive, yeah, I would wean
myself off that. I would always do it
with the doctor and the be the best way
to wean yourself off a drug is to
incorporate in other strategies as
you're weaning yourself off the drug.
for an anti-hypertensive. Incorporate
breathing techniques, incorporate
nutritional supplementation, niacin and
magnesium for example and um and uh
chromium venadium and the all the blood
sugar medication. Blood sugar, elevated
blood sugar will lead to hypertension as
well because of the whole sticky blood,
the glycated blood issue plus um blood
sugar can damage the blood vessels. When
the blood vessels are damaged, they
release inflam uh immune factors and
inflammatory factors that can that can
um damage that can uh cloth thicken the
blood or make the blood harder, more
viscous and more coagulable. So um
working with blood sugar, working with
vasoddilating nutrients like magnesium
and niain, those ones that stand out,
incorporate those as you're weaning
yourself off your medication.
Anti-hypertensives are among the most
toxic of all the drugs.
When the blood the blood pressure is
tightly tightly regulated and the blood
viscosity is tightly regulated to
override the body's desire the brain's
desire to increase the pressure takes
serious medication. So diuretics tend to
be the least
toxic of all the anti-hypertensive. It's
not they're not really antihypertensives
but the drugs they give you for high
blood pressure. Diuretics tend to be the
least toxic. the beta blocker drugs, the
calcium channel blocker drugs, the drug
drugs that work with the nervous system.
Those are the most toxic ones and those
are the ones that you really want to
wean yourself off of as quickly as
possible.
>> So, here's a question. You were talking
about the the Z radical or fuccoidin and
that that mucous slime that it helps to
create. If somebody is on an oxygen
machine or oxygen condens condenser,
should they take more
of like the fucoidin?
>> Sure.
>> You can take as much fcoin as you want.
It's completely non-toxic. You take the
whole bottle if you want it. There's no
toxicity.
>> It tastes really good. It's not hard to
do.
>> No, I didn't say zrdical. I said I never
say zratical. I always say fucoy z. The
zrdle is like a beverage. It's a ton. I
mean, it tastes good. But you don't get
the medicine. The real medicine is in
the capsules.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> I I wanted you to
>> And you can take all And you can take as
many of those cap as many of those
capsules as you want.
>> Okay. Perfect. All right. Well, um we do
have some questions. Are you ready to go
through some questions?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Okay. So, one, I have an individual
wanting to know if there's anything that
they are taking and I have their list.
So, I'll read that to you. Um, that
would cause white blood cell count to be
highly elevated. There's
>> white blood cell count.
>> Are you saying any supplements would
cause their white blood cells to be
elevated?
>> Yes, that's what the
>> white Well, what do white blood cells
do?
>> They Well,
>> they fight bacteria. They fight enemies.
>> They fight the bad guys and fight. Yeah.
When you have elevated blood cells,
there's probably some kind of infection
going on. That's why you have elevated
blood cells. Nutritional supplements are
not infectious.
You're not going to you're not going to
elevate your white blood cells from
nutritional supplements. You will
elevate your white blood cells from some
kind of infectious material or
infectious um process bacteria
specifically. White blood cells are part
of the ways the immune system fights the
bad guys.
>> Yes.
Now there are cancers. There's also
cancers that will uh uh um be
cause elevated white blood cells like
lymphas and such. But aside from that,
if you have elevated white blood cells,
that's a sign there's some kind of
infection.
>> You gave the right answer.
Okay. So, Royce, who is here with us,
wants to know, "How can I train myself
to breathe more deeply when I'm not
thinking about it?"
>> Yeah, that's a good question because
when we don't think about it, especially
if we're under stress, that's when we
breathe shallow. You have to pay
attention. You have to be mindful of it.
How you train yourself is you train
yourself in mindfulness. Personally,
you can use first of all, you should we
should all be doing breathing exercises,
you know, regularly. I do them every
morning. Um, but also you can train
yourself to use your stress levels as a
cue to breathe. So when you notice that
you're anxious or you notice you have
racing thoughts um or you notice that
you have um some kind of anxiety issues
or some kind of stress issues or
something you don't feel right, you feel
jittery, um you can use that as a cue to
kick to to start breathing uh to start
breathing more slowly and deeply and
rhythmically. So use your symptoms as a
cue or use the anxiety symptoms as a
cue.
>> Well, in um out on YouTube, uh Don says
after doing 10 minutes of 478 deep
breathing for the week.
>> It has totally transformed my mood and
sense of calm. It really works.
>> Exactly. Well, yeah, it really works.
It's oxygen. You know, you can go you
can go 40 days without food. You can go
uh you know, four days without water.
Not not that long, but you could
probably go a day or two without water.
But you can't go two minutes or three
minutes without oxygen. In fact, if you
want to if you want to experience a
panic attack, if you ever decide you
want to experience a panic attack attack
for whatever reason, say you have a
friend who has a panic gets panic
attacks and you want to know what it
feels like, hold your breath. And you
will notice that if you try to hold your
breath for like a minute, most people
can't hold their breath for a minute
unless they've been practicing. But if
you can hold your breath for like 20
seconds,
>> notice how at the end of 20, 25, 30
seconds, you have this massive desire to
breathe. And if you override that and
say, "No, I'm not going to breathe. I'm
going to force myself to not breathe."
After about 45 seconds or a minute,
depending on if you've been practicing
or not, you're going to notice that you
start to shake and you start to get hot.
You start to get red and you have all
the experiences, all the experiences of
a panic attack. And for folks who get
panic attacks, notice that before you
have your panic attack, you're not
breathing or you're holding your breath.
And by the way, one of the ways we deal
one of the I don't know if it's one of
the ways we deal with it, but one of the
things that happens when we're under
severe stress is we hold our breath. And
you can even do this if you think about
this right now. If you think about
something that's bothering you, like a I
don't know, credit card bill or
relationship issue or job or whatever,
notice how you hold your breath for a
split second. Can you feel it? Think
about something that bothers you. And
notice how you hold your breath.
>> I'm just thinking about it. I'm not
breathing.
>> Right. Right. You're not going to
breathe. When you think about it, you'll
hold your breath. It's one of the ways
we pro It's one of the ways we don't
feel. Holding the breath keeps you from
feeling your feelings.
When you start to breathe, when you
start to breathe, you'll notice you feel
your feelings, your emotions a lot more
acutely with the breath. And this is one
of the reasons why we don't breathe as
much as we should is because we don't
want to feel the pain. We don't want to
feel the the the things the emotions
that are stored in our bodies. And in
fact, massage therapists know that when
they when people get massage when people
get massages, sometimes they relax so
much they'll start to feel things and
they'll start to cry. So breathing or or
not breathing is actually a coping
mechanism for dealing with unpleasant
feelings, unpleasant emotions. And
breathing at first will activate
sometimes unpleasant emotions, but if
you get through it, it's an extremely
pleasurable, unbelievably pleasurable.
In fact, I should give a plug right now
for something called vivation.
V i va t i o n. Vivation is an
absolutely phenomenal
breathing practice. And you can
actually, there's a organization in
Wyoming uh where they actually teach you
how to do this. There's a really cool
one of my favorite books. I have
multiple copies of this book is about
vivation vivio n and they they um have
they they do rapid breathing really fast
breathing to activate incredible
pleasure responses. So breathing is an
amazing way to tap into joy, pleasure,
bliss, emotions, feelings, not to
mention uh to improve physiologic
health.
>> Well, AJ says, "Let's all try a panic
attack for fun." And I'm going to say
no.
No.
>> All right.
>> Um, and then Barbara agrees that not
being able to get your breath will
definitely cause panic. Um, then the
question is, what's the difference
between a panic attack and an anxiety
attack?
>> I nomenclature just I think they're bas
basically the same thing.
>> Yeah. Anxiety and panic. Probably
anxiety is not as severe as panic. panic
is I've never had a panic attack but I
can only imagine what that must that
must be terrible must be absolutely
terrible.
Yeah, I can't I can't imagine. But all
right, next topic that and this is going
back to where you have talked before
about arginine and its benefits for the
skin. Question is, what's been what is
Ben's opinion of using arginine amino
acid supplements?
>> They're incredibly valuable. They're not
they're just they're I call arginine
super amino acid. An amino acid is a
carbohydrate
except for one thing.
An amino acid, first of all, I should
say this. Sugar and fats are
carbohydrates.
They're both carbohydrates. Carbohydrate
means carbo carbon hide hydrogen
uh rate oxygen. Carbo or eight oxygen
carbohydrate
is carbon hydrogen and oxygen. So both
sugar and fat qualify as carbohydrates.
Okay. Does that make sense? They're both
Yeah. But both sugar and fats are
technically made up of carbon, hydrogen,
and oxygen. So they're carbohydrates by
literal definition. Okay? Even though
they're classified differently because
there they have different properties in
the body. But from an organic chemistry
perspective, sugar and fat are both
carbohydrates from an organic chemistry
perspective. And protein is also a
carbohydrate except for one thing.
Protein has a little nuclear bomb
attached to it.
This nuclear bomb turns carbohydrate
into what's called a protein. So a
protein is carbohydrate plus a nuclear
bomb. It's not a nuclear bomb. I'm I'm
exaggerating a little bit. It's not
really a nuclear bomb. But from an
organic chemistry perspective, it's kind
of like a nuclear bomb in this sense. If
you take gly if you take glycerin,
>> you know what glycerin is? It's like
sweet. It's it's it's almost like a
sugar. It's used in skincare products.
Very benign stuff. Completely non-toxic.
>> But if you stick something onto that
glycerin, you could blow apart a
mountain and build a highway.
>> What is that thing that you can stick on
glycerin to turn it into this explosive
stuff that would blow up a mountain?
>> Nitrogen.
>> Bingo. It makes it into nitroglycerin,
right? Nitroglycerin is super explosive.
Glycerin is inert. Doesn't do anything.
But by simply by putting a nitrogen
molecule onto glycerin, you get
nitroglycerin,
right?
>> If you take nail polish remover
or one of these
>> tuine isn't is nail polish remover. And
you put nitrogen in there. Tuine isn't
going to isn't going to blow up a
mountain. But if you put nitrogen on the
tuine, you get tri nitroine. Three
nitrogens. You get tri nitroine. TNT
dynamite. So nitrogen is powerful stuff.
It's super super powerful stuff. What
makes a protein so much more powerful in
terms it really is the the main player
in all of biochemistry. Everything else
supports proteins.
What makes a protein or an amino acid
distinct from a carbohydrate is
nitrogen.
carbo amino acids are carbohydrates plus
nitrogen. I called it a nuclear bomb,
but really it's just nitrogen. Okay,
what makes arginine so amazing is it's
got four nitrogens, not just one
nitrogen. And that makes it a super
powerful, probably the most powerful of
all the amino acids because of its
amazing nitrogenous property. Super
super nitrogenous. And so arginine is
very important for building things
especially and for the skin. It's
important for building skins, for people
have burns, topical arginine, internal
arginine for for muscle building, for
anabolism in general, for sugar
metabolism, arginine for the heart, for
nitric oxide. Remember, nitric oxide is
one of your body's most important, if
not your body's most important
anti-inflammatories, vasoddilators,
healing molecules. And arginine is how
the body makes nitric oxide. So arginine
is incredibly important for the heart,
for the vascular system, for healing,
for the brain, for diabetics, for nitric
oxide, for vasoddilation. It's just a
fabulously fabulously for growth
hormone. It's just an incredible
incredibly important amino acid. I call
it super amino because it's got four
nitrogens.
Now, I I have heard um it's been years
and years that for for those that may
have like a herpes virus
>> Yes.
>> that you want to
>> Why would that be based on what I just
said? Yeah. But based on what I just
said, why would that be?
>> Um because it
>> because the virus
>> racist.
>> Yes. Yes. the virus um bees on like
everything it grows on arginine too. So
there's a relationship between arginine
and lysine and lysine will balance out
or counteract some of the arginine
effects. So the people have cold sores
will sometimes say I don't want to use
arginine but that that's really not
smart because arginine is so important
for a lot of other things. If you have
cold sores it's not an arginine issue
it's an immune system issue. So the
herpes virus, yes it's true everything
grows with arginine. So you know the
virus will respond to arginine by
growing but and that's why they give you
lysine because that kind of balances out
arginine. But really if you get cold
sores it's not an arginine.
>> Okay.
Oh.
Um
>> yes.
>> Okay. Yeah. I just had something pop up.
I'm not quite sure. Ruthan, I don't know
if you see that or not. Um, so here
we've got another question
wanting to know um,
oh, where did it go? The popup got in
the way. So, if you
are
well, okay, so we're we've talked about
breathing. We've talked about all the
different symptoms that are kind of
they're dependent on breathing. It's
like life itself is dependent on
breathing and oxygen. Um, Edgar wants to
know, "What can I use to help with
Parkinson's?"
>> Parkinson's is one of Yeah. Yeah.
Parkinson's is one of the easiest
chronic health challenges to deal with.
It's unbelievably easy. I've been
working with a guy in Alabama and within
a week he was on all kinds of drugs.
Well, he was on cinemat which is the
main drug but he was on other drugs too
and nothing was helping him and he was
getting nauseous from the cinemat dizzy
and he called me up about four years ago
and within a week he was almost like
completely improved and he's been
improving ever since. I just talked to
him a couple days ago. Uh it's so simple
to treat Parkinson's. It breaks my heart
to people see people suffering and going
to the doctor and not getting any help.
First of all, almost everybody who has
Parkinson's disease has a history of
digestive health issues, intestinal
health issues. That alone should tell
you how you're going to deal with
Parkinson's disease. Just working on
digestive health. And now if you say,
"Oh, I I have Parkinson, but I don't
have digestive health iss I don't have
any intestinal problems." That's not
possible because if you have
Parkinson's,
you're not going to be Parkinson's
disease. dopamine and the
neurotransmitters that are that cause
Parkinson's are also going to have uh
lead to uh motility issues, gut motility
issues. But almost everybody before they
had the Parkinson's has a history that
way. And I've been saying this for
years, but now you can actually go
online, you can research it. There's so
much research on the relationship
between disbiosis,
leaky gut, chronic constipation, and
Parkinson's disease. That's and you know
I was talking to AJ the other day about
it and now they give you fecal
transplants for Parkinson's disease. So
it is a food issue and the it sounds you
know almost everything relates to that
and I always say that and I feel like
sometimes it doesn't it just doesn't
compute or we don't want to hear it but
that is the main way our body interacts
with the environment is through food.
Parkinson's has to always be regarded as
a food issue first and foremost. So,
food diary, eliminate problem foods.
This one gentleman who I've been working
with, he lives in Alabama and he of
course he was eating, you know, chicken
fried steak and all the, you know, fried
foods that people eat down south. And he
he I told him to do food diary and all
of a sudden he said to me, "Every time I
have fried food, every time I have
bread, every time I have cereal, my
shaking gets worse." So, first and
foremost, you want to regard it as a
food issue and an intestinal health
issue and a digestive health issue.
That's first and foremost. There's also
other strategies you can use. Activating
the parasympathetic nervous system.
Relaxing. It's very hard to have tremors
when you're taking a bath. Most people
with Parkinson's disease are not going
to shake when they're taking a bath. Why
is that? Because when you're taking a
bath, you activate the parasympathetic
nervous system. You relax all the
muscles. Now, obviously, you can't sit
in the bathtub all day, but you can take
a bath once or twice a day. And you
could also practice your slow deep
rhythmic breathing when you're shaking
when you have the shakes. So that's
another strategy that you could use. Uh
then there's also nutrients you could
use. Nascin can be very helpful. In fact
now nasin there's some similarities
between nasin and nicotine. And actually
now there are people using nicotine
patches for Parkinson's disease. Also um
co-enzyme Q10 for Parkinson's disease.
ubiquinon versus ubiquininal or either
way probably
both of them will work. All the B
complex thamine is very important. Um
amino acids are very important the amino
acids that can help you build dopamine
particularly tyrrosine and phenol
alanine. These are two amino acids that
are involved in dopamine production. Um
just general good health issu just all
the things we all have to do. We don't
want to look at these chronic
degenerative diseases as these unique
special aberrations that are happening
in the body. They're just signs that the
body's breaking down. Parkinson's
disease happens to affect a part of the
brain. They call it the substantion
which is a part of the brain
where dopamine is made. But if you have
u a degeneration a little bit to the to
the right, you'll end up with another
kind of brain disorder. It doesn't
really matter where the brain disorder
is or where the degeneration is. The
fact is is that there's degeneration and
that's what you want to and that's what
you want to um that's what you want to
be dealing with. This idea of special
diseases and specialists, it only serves
the specialists. It doesn't serve the
patients. The patients never benefit
from these special recommendations. What
can somebody honestly if you have
Parkinson's disease and you go to the
doctor, okay, what the heck do you think
the doctor's going to do? Is he going to
wave a magic wand and now you don't have
Parkinson's anymore? Of course not. He's
going to give you the same stupid drugs
that have been they've been given for 50
years. Cinemat, you know, uh, leodopa,
you'll get the same thing. Why leodopa?
Because your brain's not making
dopamine. So, they give you leodopa.
They're not going to help you with the
degeneration. They're going to give you
the leodopa. There's nothing the doctor
can do for Parkinson's disease. Nothing.
Unless he gives you tells you to take
care of your diet and does what we tell
you on the on this program. It's
lifestyle. Got to get this out of our
heads. That health is medical. Medical
is when you get hit by a car. Medical is
when a rock falls on your head. Medical
is when you get a burn or trauma.
Lifestyle issues like diabetes and
Parkinson's disease and and heart
disease. These are lifestyle. And that
should be the best news anybody hears
who's dealing with these kinds of things
because it means we can do it ourselves.
That's the most important message here
is we can do this oursel. Yeah, this
doctor can't help you with your heart
disease, but he can we can do it. He
can't help you with your diabetes, but
we can do it. He can't help you with
your Parkinson's or your dementias. We
can do it. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
>> Well, earlier you had said, you know,
we're always looking to blame something,
but something we don't want to blame is
ourselves and our own choices. But
unless we know information like what we
share here on with Doc, we don't know.
>> We don't. Nobody's giving us these
options because the whole system is
skewed to make money
>> and it's skewed to disempower. I you
know you never if you if you're healthy,
you know this. If you're not healthy and
you're already in the system, you know,
you also probably know, but it's too
late. Don't want to be in the system.
You do not want to be part of the
system. They will they'll they'll own
you. They'll carve out your organs.
They'll poison you and they won't help
you and you'll be a number. And God
forbid if it's, you know, if if it's
free, like in in Europe or even on in
Medicaid, you know, if you ever have to
go to the VA, you know what I'm talking
about. When medicine is free and you're
into the system, it's not in your
interest. It's always the institution
versus the individual. The system is the
institution. The institution only cares
about keeping itself healthy. It doesn't
care about keeping you healthy. It wants
to maintain its hegemony, its its
authority,
its financial well-being. That's what
the institutions are about. Now, I'm not
make I'm not trying to cast dispersions
on individual doctors because the
doctors are good people. It's the
institution that's the problem. The
doctors are not bad people. It's the
it's the institution of medicine that's
locked into place. That's where that's
where it's pitted against the
individual. And by the way, these days
doctors don't even work for themselves.
They work for the institutions. They
work for the HMOs. There's very little
doc I remember when they did house
calls. Remember when doctors used to
come to your house?
>> That doesn't that don't happen no more.
They all work for Kaiser,
>> you know, and they for Sigma
>> and now they have their protocols
>> and they have care. They got Yes. Yes.
especially if they work for an HMO, they
have, you know, the HMO will make a deal
with the drug company. They'll get the
cheap drugs and they'll they'll you'll
get you'll automatically get this beta
blocker or this calcium channel blocker.
You know, it's all listed exactly what
you get. And there's like four or you go
in for to the doctor with heart disease,
you're going to get a standard four or
five uh uh pharmaceutical protocol.
Everybody gets the same thing.
>> Yes.
>> You don't that's not the way we want to
deal with these things. And the proof of
it is we got more doctors than ever
before, more HMOs, more drugs. We're
spending more money than ever before. We
got more devices and protocols and and
surgical procedures. And we're just as
sick. We're sicker than ever before. It
doesn't work.
>> No, that's a clue. Well, we do have two
hands up, so let's try to squeeze in at
least one. And
Marilyn, thank you for patiently
waiting.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Then you had mentioned nicotine
patches help with Parkkins. Can you say
a little bit more about that?
>> Yeah, nicotine patches have been used. I
I like, you know, nicotine is it's not
it's a drug and so I prefer people use
nasin, but yes, nicotine patches
activate the um the the parasympathetic
relaxation nervous system, the the
cononergic nervous system. It's thought
that that's one reason why people smoke
is to activate their parasympathetic
nervous system or their coneric nervous
system. So um you know nicotine is still
a toxin and it's a drug uh and niacin
will do the same thing. So I I recommend
people use nasin but there are I have
heard of people using nicotine patches
for Parkinson's. Yes.
>> Oh okay. I want to make another comment.
I used to run a lot in school. Uh I was
an athlete and I ran the 400 meters.
>> Really?
>> And Yeah. And no one ever said anything.
After the race I would have these panic
attacks because you're breathing your
heart is going miles an hour. Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so I did just what you
said. I would try to hold my breath to
try to calm the heart down and I'd get
worse. And I never asked anybody about
it. And then over time I just I just
would let my body just breathe. And that
was the best thing. Quick, no dizziness,
no panic attack. Never told me. And I'm
like holding my breath to try to slow it
down. I'm telling you, don't do that. If
you're an athlete, don't do that. just
let your your body will naturally
breathe and and you'll recover in a few
seconds.
Okay, thanks.
>> Okay,
>> awesome. Thank you so much, Marilyn and
AJ.
>> Well, Ben, thank you for everything. Uh,
>> yes.
>> And of course, of course, you woke the
Daily with Doc hotline, which is
855949337.
>> Yes. Uh, pharmacist Ben, uh, what's your
what's your favorite nutrient?
>> That's hard to say, but if I had to pick
one, if you made me pick one, vitamin C.
Why do you ask?
>> Because I if someone's got a lung issue,
>> yes.
>> Is are are l would the lungs benefit by
having copious amounts of vitamin C?
>> 100%. For a lot of reasons. First of
all, vitamin C is a potent stimulator of
nitric oxide.
And that's a vasod diilator. Vitamin C
is also an anti-inflammatory. Vitamin C
is also an antioxidant. And vitamin C
also helps stimulate the production of
collagen which is important for lung
health. So absolutely abs 100%.
>> It's one of the most important res
respiratory vitam of the respiratory
vitamins.
>> Why? What made you ask that?
>> Well, this person's got interstitial
lung problems.
Yeah, I would there I would put them on
an entire nutritional supplement
program, but I would want to know like
what else they have going on. Interest
like this is the person was who said the
with the mold.
>> Well, the mold was in an old house from
2018 and a doctor said the only thing
that's going to h help your lungs is a
transplant and
>> a lung a lung transplant.
>> This was back in 2018
>> and she's not a um and she's not a
smoker. not a smoker.
>> Well, I would want to know what
precipitated the
>> we've not been able to pinpoint. The
only thing that she's
>> another
>> Yeah. an acetylcyine also. I forgot
about that one for the lungs. NAC
>> in fact NAC is used for for cystic
fibrosis patients who have respiratory
problems.
>> Um and also vitamin C. But no, I'd want
to talk to her because interstatial uh
inter lung disease doesn't just happen.
there's got to be some stuff going on.
>> And of course, that's not that those are
all secondary to the triangle.
>> And she was a poor eater, I'm sure, back
then, too. I mean, you know, she she's
>> there could be all kinds of stuff. Yeah,
there could have could have been all
kinds of stuff. But but vitamin C, if I
had to pick my favorite um my favorite
vitamin, I'd have to say vitamin C.
Vitamin C is also an antihistamine, too.
And histamine sometimes is involved in
respiratory health issues. Vitamin C
also relaxes lung lung tissue.
So vitamin, you know, there's a lot of
great nutrients obviously, but I if you
had if I had to pick my favorite, it
would be vitamin C. And vitamin C
definitely will have a beneficial
effects on respiratory health.
>> So she take a lot of vitamin C and a lot
of slime.
>> A lot of slime, a lot of vitamin C, an
acetylcyine, glutathione, selenium,
sulfur, essential fats, omega ultimate
EFAs. There's a whole bunch of
magnesium. There's a whole bunch of
things you could take for your lungs if
you vitamin E.
>> Okay. So, pharmacist Ben, the majority
of what you're mentioning is in a
healthy body pack.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely.
>> Take a healthy body pack. Make it easy.
>> Absolutely. I would take healthy I would
do the healthy brain hard pack.
>> Even better.
>> Yeah, that's what I would do. Healthy
brain.
>> Yeah. So folks get back with the person
that shared this program with you and
ask for that healthy body actually
healthy.
>> Yeah. And also let's if anybody out
there if somebody has Parkinson's let's
make them a case study just to show you
how easy it is to deal with Parkinson's.
So if you have let's pick one person
contact Becca or AJ or somebody Marilyn
or whoever and then we'll make them a
case study.
>> All right. So contact 8559493377.
Again, that's 855-94933377
and let us know if you would like to be
a case study uh if you currently have
the symptoms of Parkinson's.
So, beautiful. All right.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you,
Pharmacist Ben Fuches.
>> And we're getting you out on time.
>> All right. Have a great day. Good to see
everybody. Monday night on nine. Monday
night.
>> Monday night. Bye. AJ and Becca and Mary
and Ruth Ellen
>> and Phyis and Albert
>> and everybody in our audience here live
with us in the Zoom or out on the
different platforms.
>> And if I could get the co-hosts up on
the screen with me, that would be
absolutely fabulous. Thank you everyone
for being here with us and plugging in
in this hour. more information that
empowers you as an individual to help
make wiser choices on what goes in the
mouth
and how to breathe.
So folks, remember lifestyle includes
your activities, what you're eating, the
way you're breathing, the way that
you're coping with stress. All of those
things
really do play an important part on your
overall health and we are here to help
you especially with that nutrient
spectrum uh that the body needs each and
every day. So if you um have some
concerns in your health and you're
wanting to speak with a certified
holistic health coach or somebody
referred you, get back with them. it's
possible. They are an amazing certified
holistic health coach or an advocate of
health that's been doing this for
decades because we've got a few of them.
And if you weren't referred to somebody
specifically and you'd like to be part
um speak to one
855-9493377.
And I also want to do a shout out. If
you're somebody that loves to work with
people, you want to see people succeed
in creating a better health journey,
we have a spot for you
or get back with a person and share this
program with you as what we do to help
others is open to others who have a
heart wanting to help others through
nutrition and lifestyle. So again,
8559493377
or get back with a person share this
program with you if you would like to be
part of a solution that is greater than
you yourself. So
I am super excited to be able to do this
program and have the individuals on the
screen. There's some that aren't here
with us today, but we do have
Phyllis who is a pioneer in helping
instruct others on the research that Dr.
Joel Wallik originally set this crusade
on. Um, he is just absolutely amazing.
So, we we do a shout out to Dr. Wall as
yesterday was his 87th birthday. And we
also have with us Mary who Mary she
she's an engineer
but man does she look at the body deep
as well. So thank you so much Mary for
being part of our co-host team. We also
have Albert. He is our gatekeeper our
warden here in the Daily with Doc Zoom.
So, thank you so much, Albert, as he is
joining us from Africa. So, if you're
calling in the middle of night during
the United States time frames, you may
be speaking with Albert as he's helping
us keep 247 on our phone team. We also
have Ruth Ellen. She is our organizer
and our uh my my right hand
as she is the executive production
manager. So, thank you so much, Ruth
Ellen, for all that you do and getting
everything organized and out onto the
different platforms. Um, and we have
Marilyn, Miss Speedy Fingers, as she is
doing dictation, putting it into the
chat. Um, so thank you so much, Marilyn.
And you know, also something that
Phyllis is doing and Mary's doing is
they're keeping an eye on the different
platforms and bringing those questions
in so we can ask and get them answered
here live in the show. And we have last
but not least, Mr. Techno, who is our
digital marketing
manager.
Thank you. I do read lips. I appreciate
that, Ralin.
Um, so thank you so much AJ for all you
do and helping us to get on all the
right platforms so we can meet people
where they're at. And for all of you who
have joined us here live in the Zoom and
those who want to
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday from 12:00
to 1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1 to 2 Mountain, 2
to 3 Central, 3 to 4 Eastern and 9 to
10, at least in this time of the year
down in South Africa PM. Um, join us by
initially going to Zoom.with
dailywithdoc.com.
Make sure that you are signed into your
Zoom account and register and then the
next time as long as your
registration has been approved, you will
be allowed into the Zoom live with us.
So again, thank you so much for
everybody for joining us. My name is
Becca Dukes and if you'd like more
information about becoming a certified
holistic health coach, go to coach c o
dailywithdoc.com.
Until next time. Bye for now. Oh, and
don't forget Monday, Monday, Monday,
Monday. Pharmacist Benites with coach
AJ. You want to make sure that you go to
stream.dailywithdoc.com
and catch that Monday 9 to10 Eastern
time. So figure it out from there.
That's 8 to 9 central.
No, just figure it out for yourself. My
brain's not working backwards today. So,
until next time, everybody. Bye for now.
This program is for educational
purposes. says only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic